ces deux irakiens avaient été arrêtés en
france la suite des attentats de ces
dernières semaines les services de
police les ont expulsés l'irak corps est
assuré qu'il n'avait pas été exécutée
alors arrivé c'est aussi ce qu'affirme
l'ambassadeur d'irak à paris rencontré
par hervé brusini les deux hommes
détenus à bagdad sont sains et saufs
affirme est à nouveau ce matin
l'ambassadeur d'irak
leur sort sera fixé par la justice de
notre pays ça dépendra le procès est le
court et le jugement
je ne peux pas dire maintenant en avant
avant qu'elles ont l'opportunité d'avoir
tous les faits sur leurs activités et
c'est le devoir de deux procès décidé le
sort des sept se tient juste une
question est-ce que avant de les
expulser
le gouvernement français vous a demandé
des garanties les concernant nous avons
été informés de l'explosion
c'est tout n'avait pas été contacté
avant l'expulsion
oui on m'a contacté avant mais pour mme
en forme et qu'il partait à bagdad
oui rien de plus dans l'un des plus ce
soit encore la question reste posée à
ton expulsé contre leur gré en irak
caire al din et à ma famille il a été
demandé à la grande bretagne au paraguay
de les recevoir
ces pays ont refusé c'est alors que la
question s'est posée de leur expulsion
dans les conditions juridiques je viens
de dire est que ressortissant irakien la
police un cul de voir les expulsés vers
leur pays
aucune protestation aucune procédure n'a
été enregistrée la veille même de leur
expulsion
trop tard selon le ministère l'intérieur
les deux hommes avait pourtant rempli
ses demandes de statut de réfugié
politique
il y expliquait que tout retour en irak
signifie pour eux une condamnation à
mort qu'ils étaient bel et bien opposant
régime de leur propre pays ils n'ont pas
pu vouloir ce jeu
tu es dans la gueule du loup insistent
les avocats légèreté bavure coups tordus
force est de constater que les
déclarations officielles ne cadre guère
avec la réalité des faits avec ce qui
s'est passé ici même au dépôt du palais
de justice le 19 février dernier